ISIL is called battleship into the
movies credit there is a battleship in
this movie somewhere like once other
than that it makes no sense to call it
that just no sense
battleship alright so with the success
of Transformers all the studios were
like alright let's just make a bunch of
movies that are they have titles of
novelties from the 80s doesn't matter if
it has anything to do with it just call
it whatever Oh even Hawk signed on for
the sequel to training day sweet we're
going to rename it operation that's not
real but I'm just saying it feels like
that first when watching the trailer to
battleship you know it really has
nothing to do with the game battleship
at first it kind of does the movie stars
the guy from John Carter so if you're in
Hollywood you're looking for an agent to
represent you because you want to be an
actor don't hire that dude agent just
saying past and they're going to do the
Naval War Games which feels like
battleship then the aliens land you're
like this is no longer battleship I'm
going to talk about what worked in the
movie though when the movie started I
was like alright we already know from
the trailer it has nothing to do with
the game battleships I'm just gonna see
this as an alien invasion movie and as
an alien invasion movie it's not so
terrible the aliens were actually quite
cool they were badasses
I like their tech I got to say if
there's one thing that's awesome in this
movie it's the alien tact like the
aliens and their suits of suits were
always shifting you know and guns were
always popping out of it it's just
everything was always shifting and
changing which sounds like transformers
that everyone said I the trailer looks
like transformers it really doesn't feel
like transformers things just always
shift and change on the alien stuff but
Star transformers and the alien ships
were really menacing they come out of
the water and they'd be floating there
like I mean this is me impersonating an
alien ship floating there I guess and it
would lock onto a battleship and it'd
just be like mom and just there it is I
felt like a velociraptor just snapped
his neck and looked at a human you're
like you're dead take heart and knowing
you have no choice but to die that thing
is going to waste you the ships are just
shipped it's not like biomechanical or
anything like that they're mechanical
ships but it really made the ships feel
alive the other thing I liked were those
weird little balls of death they're just
laying on an aircraft carrier and just
shred through that thing it was like
Looney Tunes termites you know how
Looney Tunes termites pour on wood is
just like man it just burns right
through it it's gone that's what these
things were like they were completely
cool and after that there was some cool
kick-ass Rey between you know the aliens
and
humans humans versus the aliens but now
we're gonna get to the actors and the
characters and I feel like the tone of
this review is just gonna change the
reports where I was like the acting is
just terrible in this movie it's just
bad like Oh cut some slack for some
people just because I feel like some of
the people in this movie were actually
from the Navy and if you are actual
naval personnel portraying a person
who's naval personnel in a movie I'll
give you slack you're not really an
actor but the director wanted real naval
personnel so I get it the only one who
really beat those acting odds are lee
Ermey badass in the military badass in
movies and Geico commercials what am i
Rihanna in the movie really why is she
in the movie it completely feels like
she's a singer who is in her first movie
is the other guy in fact you know what
in terms of acting I have nothing
against the guy it's just the fact that
he looks like Matt Damon's stunt double
like he looks like Matt Damon from Team
America every time he was on the screen
I just want to be like minty it's a
really petty thing to bring up in a
review but it's just what sticks out in
my head that dude who kind of looks like
Matt Damon and John Carter's character I
just didn't connect with I know they
were going for the james t kirk vibe
with his character i know they were like
alright we're gonna do james t kirk or
maverick you know you can tell he's just
like untapped potential and he just
doesn't care about anything but
throughout the movie we're gonna see him
focus we're gonna be rooting for him the
entire time but I didn't root for him I
just saw him and I'm like yeah you're
kind of a douchebag doesn't get a
about anything you feel like he's just
like dragging his girlfriend down with
him I think the problem is with james t
kirk 'i don't really see him be a
douchebag or anything like that i mean
yeah he's kind of unfocused you already
saw his dad do something heroic so you
know he has that enemy you don't have to
wait too long before he joined Starfleet
of his own accord the student battleship
his brothers like you're joining the
Navy alright so he doesn't actually want
to do that so he's pretty much the same
idiot who broke into a gas station to
impress a girl yeah he's still stupid
he's just annoying until he's not as the
best I could say it like at a point
you're like oh yeah he's going to step
up and you know it be a good commander
till that happens you're like why are
you commanding handed over to Matt Damon
I mean in terms of an alien invasion
movie it's a lot better than the other
alien invasion movies that happened over
the past couple years and so I will give
the movie that is it a great movie no is
it a fun movie
yeah you forget about it right after you
walk out of the movie you betcha
in the end I will say battleship is a
good time if you're drunk yeah
it's explosions you sunk my patrol boat
no one hits that thing if you just want
a fun summer alien invasion movie with a
lot of explosions and a few fights and
some tech that's really cool you don't
really care about characters or anything
like that you're gonna have a pretty fun
time with the movie if you require more
than that it's gonna be what you
probably expect all right so your
favorite alien invasion movie I feel
like I already asked you that question
but I don't care we got new people here
we got new subscribers I want to know
their favorite alien invasion movie what
is it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more